what's going on guys this is Rob and I
just wanted to say thank you I want to
say thank you guys so much
I was sown I was so hesitant I was so
unsure about how to do these tires I
like really like genuinely I didn't know
what to do
like I was just kind of sitting here and
I was like I don't know what to do like
I don't know what to do with these
tie-ins I don't know how to post them I
don't know I don't know what what people
want and then it dawned on me like you
guys are my subscribers you guys are
here to help me succeed you know and I'm
here to bring you content that you guys
want to see so I figured who better to
ask like why would I ask anybody other
than my subscribers what it is that you
guys want to see so you know I posted
the video asking you guys how you guys
wanted me the new tie-ins and you guys
responded in full force you guys gave me
so many awesome ideas I mean Dan was
saying stuff like do videos on Monday
and videos on Thursday a couple other
people were saying the same thing you
know people were saying split the videos
up you know you guys said a lot of
really cool stuff so here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do an amalgamation of
all those things every Monday is gonna
be a main story of Civil War that's
gonna be the main Civil War event it'll
be so work is your number three issue
number four if you're number five so on
and so forth Thursday's will be the
tie-ins
and we'll split the videos up I'm not
gonna make you guys sit down and watch
an hour-long video about tie-ins so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna split the
video into like maybe two or three
videos depending on how long the tie
ends go because I admit spoken
previously between civil war issue
number three and Civil War issue number
four
there's 22 tie-ins so that really kind
of mandates that we split the videos up
and so what I'll do is I'll have them
split up as like maybe two or three
videos they'll be around I don't know
maybe 15 20 minutes apiece hopefully
there won't be too much longer than that
if they end up I'm gonna try to keep
each video of each video around 15 to 20
minutes if it ends up running longer
then we'll just split it up more so that
way we really want to have any videos
that are longer than 20 minutes so that
way you know the final video might be
like 7 or 8 minutes or it might be 5
minutes or it might be 3 minutes or
whatever the case may be but it'll be
split up into two reasonable sized
chunks that way you guys can sit down
and watch it on like a lunch break where
you guys can sit down and watch it you
know as a break from homework or
whatever is it you guys are doing at the
time when you guys can digest the bits
of information that I'm giving you in a
pretty a pretty good way you know and
and you know again that's you guys this
whole thing is you guys I mean this is
your idea this is not my idea you know
so you guys deserve a count on the back
and you Pat yourselves on the back
because this is 100% you and this is why
I love you guys so much because you guys
are so supportive you guys are so
awesome in this you know the fact that I
can make a video and say what do you
guys want to see and you guys are like
we want to see this and I can say done
that's it that's exactly how we're gonna
do it I love that element it's no muss
no fuss
it's clear-cut you know you guys know
what you want you know I know what I
want and there's really no debate here
in terms of how it's gonna be presented
you know you guys to me what you want to
see I'll bring you guys what you want to
see and that's it now to the bad part
now to the downside my schedule this
week is a nuts I am going into work at 7
p.m. today it's like 3:30 in the
afternoon I'm working at 7 p.m. today
and I get off at 7 a.m. in the morning
so 7 a.m. Monday morning I has to be
back into work at 3 p.m. Monday morning
or Monday afternoon and I get off work
at 11 p.m. Monday night then I go back
into work at 11 p.m. Tuesday night and
then I work until 7 a.m. Wednesday
morning and then I go back into work
again 11 p.m. on Thursday night I'm
sorry Wednesday night and then I get off
at 7 a.m. Thursday morning and then I
think I'm off on Thursday but I'm not
sure but I'm working 12 hours
back-to-back so I think it's 12 hours on
Friday and Saturday or as 12 hours on
Thursday and Friday I don't remember but
it's my schedule is ridiculous because
one of the guys took off there's
normally three of us covering three two
shifts but one of the guys took off for
a week so there's two of us covering two
shifts and it's crazy like it's
absolutely nuts so the downside is I've
got half of all the times between civil
war issues number two and three
completely finished and my intention was
to have those videos uploaded today on
Sunday but I just didn't have time that
I just didn't have enough time to finish
it you know I'm yeah just you know I'm
just now finishing half of the audio for
that thing I haven't even started any of
the of the coming but panels or anything
so there's just not enough time so I
probably won't have another video
uploaded until Thursday but the good
thing is this it will allow us to
continue this trend so on Thursday we'll
have the Civil War video split up
the time split up however they need to
be split up so you guys can watch them
and then on Monday we'll do Civil War
part 3 and then on on Wednesday
well I'm sorry next next Thursday we'll
do the tie ends between Civil War issues
number 3 and 4 and then the following
Monday we'll do a Civil War part 4 and
then so on and so forth and you know
until the whole series is over hope you
know I know it sucks I know it sucks I
really know it does and and I'm
disappointed that I can't finish the
video and bring it to you guys because I
really really want to you know I really
want to finish the video and bring it to
you guys but you know I mean I've got a
I've got to eat and you know as you guys
know you know I mean money buys food and
it buys it makes my makes me be able to
pay rent you know I don't think it makes
any sense it makes it so I can pay rent
in my apartment and it gives me food on
you know I guess food to eat and clothes
my back anyway it makes it so I can take
care of myself basically and so you know
my job comes first you know now when the
time comes where where that changes when
the time comes where I can make these
videos full-time and I can leave my
current position then consistency will
be there but for right now you know it's
inconsistent and I'm sorry I'm sorry I
can't be as consistent as I would like
to be but it's just the nature of trying
to balance a full-time job with doing
YouTube which is kind of how it goes
you know but again you know once all
that changes and once I'm able to do
these videos full-time it'll make life a
whole lot easier but until then just
bear with me you know just you know
trying to try to stay with me on this
one I know it'll be kind of chaotic I
know it sucks that I can't give you a
video as consistently as you would like
but it's just kind of part and parcel
with the whole thing so and after that
there was an idea all right listen let's
kind of transition here there was an
idea that I've been kicking around and
I've kind of been mulling around and I
don't know how you guys feel about it
but when I was part of the call of duty
community I knew how difficult it could
be to grow a YouTube channel I knew that
if no one really extended a helping hand
there was really no way for you to grow
and part of that was due to the fact of
the gaming community was so saturated
because there were so many people doing
gaming videos and part of that was due
to the fact that the call of duty
community was so saturated and there
were so many people doing Call of Duty
video
and you know there was one guy that
helped me out but there wasn't a big
huge response from it you know and I
wouldn't really know really didn't
expect her to be because there were so
many other people out there but an idea
that I've been kicking around is kind of
opening my channel up to people to
allowing other users to upload videos to
my youtube channel or at least I would
upload it for though I'm not gonna give
them access to my YouTube channel but
you know I would let them submit their
videos to me and I would upload them
onto my youtube channel taking like one
day out of the week to do that maybe you
like oh like Wednesday or something like
that or Sunday you know but you know
maybe like subscribers Saturday
subscribers Sunday I'm not really sure
what it would be called but basically
that just would be this it would be
videos from a wide array of different
things I'm not gonna confine it to comic
books I'm not going to say you know you
can only upload videos regarding comic
books it would be an upload for all
different kinds of videos on YouTube you
know whether you're doing blogs like
jenna Marbles or you're doing
playthroughs like PewDiePie or something
like that
you know you would be able to upload or
submit videos to me and I would upload
them to my youtube channel is that
something you guys are interested in
would you guys really like that you know
I would like to do it because I think it
would be something that would be awesome
because it would give people who are
really small a chance to grow you know
by no means am i a huge big youtuber but
it would give people who were just now
starting out on YouTube a chance to grow
in addition it would give them exposure
to a big time YouTube audience because
as you guys know right when it was a big
time I don't know why I keep saying like
Big Time stuff it would give them a
chance to expose themselves to an
established YouTube audience because
when you're first starting out on
YouTube when you're first
you know uploading your videos onto
YouTube there really aren't a whole lot
of people you can submit it to different
forms but it's not the same as if you
were submitting it to 8,000 subscribers
you know it's it's not the same you
don't get the same kind of reaction you
don't get the same kind of response and
so it would very least give these people
a chance to to see how a subscriber
bation 8,000 people would react you know
um yeah I would ask you guys don't be
about it yeah just don't you
know I mean if it's a new guy I don't
get on there and be like oh you guys are
dicks you know you're or you guys suck
you know your contents crap in your crap
you know mean don't don't be like that
you know I mean they don't but you know
help help teach them you know the way
that you guys have kind of helped guide
me and my youtube channel do
the same for them you know and say hey
look you know you could be doing this
better you could be doing that better
you know I didn't necessarily like this
you know your mic could be better
quality whatever the case may be you
know help guide them and teach them what
they need to know in order to succeed on
YouTube because my success on YouTube I
attribute to you guys I mean sure you
know I make videos that you guys like
but you know you guys are the reason why
I've been successful you guys are the
ones that are going around and posting
to all kinds of websites and you guys
are the ones that are tweeting this
stuff out and you guys are the ones that
are telling your friends you know and
all that kind of stuff my success is
because of you guys and so I would ask
that you guys extend that same kind of
drive to whoever it is it's uploaded
onto my channel at the time now I
understand that you guys won't like
everything that gets uploaded I mean if
you guys don't like games you probably
won't like Call of Duty gameplay you
guys probably won't like you know
playthroughs or anything like that and
that's fine you know that's okay I don't
have a problem with that you know the
one thing that I ask is that you guys
just kind of understand that it will be
a place for a lot of people with a lot
of different content to upload so they
can gain exposure you know so that they
can you know really kind of get a chance
to make themselves known it may not
happen it may just be that somebody gets
a video on here and nobody cares you
know it may be the person uploads a
video on here and they become the next
PewDiePie who knows you know it's really
just kind of a toss in the air but it's
an idea that I've been kicking around
and it's an idea that I've been
considering and I think it's a good one
I really like this idea so let me know
what you guys think let me know if
that's something you guys want to see
and yeah so that's that's pretty much it
I think um oh by the way so dave has
this channel online as comics reviews
channel on law and they'll be a link
down in the description and of course
I'll add him to the post role for the
videos that I upload so you guys can
check his channel out and you know let
him know what you think you know of
course you know give them feedback and
he's part of the whole group with me and
me and Benny and you know of course Dave
as part of it as part of our podcast you
know so treat him with the same kind of
courtesy that you would treat Benny you
know if you know when you're on his
channel or you know he's he's part of
the podcast or anything like that you
know so he's one of our guys you know
he's he's one of us
you know so don't you know he's he's
part of he's part of our whole big you
know 8,000 subscribers youtube channel
comic book world kind of thing that we
have going on here you know so so treat
him like one of us you know shoot him
like one of our guys so um
yeah I'm gonna go ahead and I guess
bring this video to an end and that was
pretty much it so anyway we're going on
for like 11 minutes so I'll catch you
guys later peace